in the film you have your character has
a broken leg but that was not part of
the script it was not
I broke my leg the night before I went
to shoot this film in Savannah and
thanks guys what was that nice ooh
before when I needed and they're all for
you apparently so I broke my leg I
didn't I so I I had this weird fall in
my apartment and I was still walking on
it might you know I was supporting
weight on my leg and it wasn't swollen
so I was like I think it's okay and then
like about halfway through the Delta
terminal at JFK which is not exact not
exaggerating like a mile long it's a
good one it's a long one and I'm and I
have my child my eight month old
strapped to my chest and I'm now in
severe pain I'm like I think that
there's something wrong here so I landed
and went to the doctor and indeed I had
a broken leg and we had a broken leg and
didn't know it like it is so badass
that's incredible great no I'm serious
good for you I'm broken well I suppose I
was still walking around and it was it
was a bone that wasn't weights like a we
do doesn't matter I could break a small
piece of cartilage in my ear and I would
be in a bed for nine years I think I
need to take a page from you because
that's probably what I should have done
but it was this small it's this lovely
movie and I just didn't want to let them
down so I did the movie and we we ended
up working it into the script of my
character had a broken leg and and
people think it was a choice and not a
real that's nice I mean if you were
playing like spider-man it would be a
choice what you want to after that night
exactly
well we have a clip from the
intervention and I believe this is this
is the first time this movie is about my
character she's married and the this
group of friends were all close and they
decide to host an intervention on my
marriage because they think that it's
not a good one and so we're arriving at
this beautiful place for the first time
let's take a look at this clip from the
intervention done okay
[Applause]
all right we would have been here
earlier but Peter was on a very
important phone call in your head no you
checked on the kids yet we just got here
Peter so no don't kill me because we
haven't called since we landed okay so
just so everyone knows it was just
drinks being served out and back on the
porch no make him happy drink yeah I
think we should settle in first before
we Peter is there anything else you want
to micromanage I just like one drink
okay
[Applause]
I know but I don't know if you're like
this Andy but I am I'm when I'm watching
a scene where a couple isn't getting
along and you you're you guys are good
actors I get extremely uncomfortable
like I just got very and when I'm in a
restaurant and two people aren't getting
along I'm very very uncomfortable way to
sell the movie Conan it's the most
anxious film you'll see this fall feel
like getting stressed check it out
well it's a terrific movie I love it
when marriage is just crumbled no no I
didn't say it what would happen at the
ending and you just did I'm saying in
general there's a lot in general yes in
general okay you never know no spoilers
isn't that what the kids say hash tag
yeah I listen to all the new albums the
intervention in that new disc by that
new artist
you